I'm gonna figure it all out I promise  you wrong all gonna learn Khloe  Kardashian has been pretty confident  about her impending motherhood up until  this point but now she admits she's  nervous about one thing  after Coco shared this pic from her  maternity shoot with Tristan Thompson on  Monday showing off her cleavage and baby  bump one Instagram follower commented  with some insight on how her pregnancy  boobs might change once she gives birth  to her first child  Chloe replied oh my gosh lol I'm nervous  about breastfeeding  I hear crazy things but I'll fight  through it and love it I feel great and  I feel so lucky to feel so great I hear  so many horror stories and when you're  pregnant people for some reason tell you  more horror stories which is so mean  [Music]